[Musique]
François Bayrou Bonjour bonjour Merci
d'être avec nous nous en parler de
politique évidemment mais je voudrais
commencer avec le covit 47000 nouveau
cas en 24 heure en France alors
plusieurs questions sont posées j'ai vu
que l'Allemagne réfléchissais à rendre
la vaccination obligatoire pour
l'ensemble de la population doit-on
ouvrir cette réflexion en France oui
comme vous savez c'est ma position
depuis le début de 2021 depuis depuis
qu'on a su que le vaccin était un
efficace et 200 effets secondaires.
Quasiment sans effet secondaire
et donc moi je pense que comme pour
toutes les grandes épidémies comme pour
la polio comme pour la rougeole qui
faisait beaucoup de morts il y a un
moment où les autorités médical 10 c'est
pas possible il faut à tout prix
contrarier la circulation du virus et
pas seulement parce que ça fait de
nouveau malade et parce que plus le
virus est transmis plus il y a des
choses qu'il mute et il peut monter
en deux venant quelque chose de terrible
j'ai déjà dit je crois chez vous mais je
vais je vais répéter le loyer ma hantise
moi comme oui ma hantise c'est que une
mutation du virus ne lui permettent de
s'attaquer aux petits-enfants
bébé et aux petits-enfants
si ça se produisait et ce que Dieu ne
plaise
conjuguons toutes nos forces pour
empêcher ça si ça se produisait notre
société n'y résisterai pas notre société
dit résiste parce que je ne pouvais pas
accepter que des petits-enfants sois
touché par une maladie qu'on aurait pu
éviter qu'on pourrait l'étang de rendre
la vaccination obligatoire la conviction
c'est que ce débat doit être ouvert il
faut le faire dans le calme oui mais
nous avons déjà 11 vaccination
obligatoire en France 11 pour chef pour
chacun des enfants qui n'est
quel quel problème il y aurait-il est
donc ma conviction c'est celle-là c'est
que dans un moment où nos sociétés tout
de société sur la planète pour ils sont
attaqués par un agent pathogène comme on
dit par un virus qu'on se combattre
d'once effréné la transmission et
surtout tonton c'est freiner la gravité
il y a il y a dans les chiffres que vous
avez fait effrayant 47000 on en revient
au sommet des comme au sommet des cours
mais il y a un aspect un peu rassurant
c'est que pour l'instant il n'y a pas
la multiplication des cas gravissime à
l'hôpital c'est d'une certaine manière
freinée alors il y a de grâce au vaccin
qui empêche oui que la maladie ne dérape
dans quelque chose de très grave bien
donc vaccination oui il est temps
d'ouvrir la réflexion plus que la
réflexion et temps de prendre des
décisions et
donc
oui je pense que c'est une décision qui
doit être à l'esprit des autorités qui
ont la responsabilité autre question sur
le vide est-ce qu'il faut rendre les
tests pc gratuit détecter isoler tracer
alors je
n'arrive pas à comprendre oui qu'on
croit qu'un test et une manière efficace
de lutter parce que entre le moment où
on fait le test et le moment où on
devient contagieux oui il y a toute une
période oui vous avez reçu beaucoup
d'épidémiologie si vous demain le
président du conseil scientifique
Jean-François le prix sera votre place
ou à peu près c'est cette période de
délai dandy période de latence entre le
entre le test est la maladie qui se
déclare et le fait qu'on devienne
contagieux qui est extrêmement
dangereuse et donc je mange crois
davantage à la à la vaccination que tu
est bien et puis dernière question
est-ce qu'il faut
parce que
si tu habites dans 10 pays
alors il peut y avoir des démarches
international mais cette question qui
paraît se résoudre de manière simpliste
mérite que une seconde en rappelle
quelque chose si nous avons des vaccins
c'est parce qu'il y a eu de la recherche
privée c'est parce que des laboratoires
on l'investit
milliards oui et est-ce qu'ils avaient
se tirer des milliards s'ils étaient
appelés à être privé ou une fruit de
leur maintenant le retour c'est vraiment
il y a d'autres recherches en tout cas
moi je demande à ce qu'on soit prudent
avant d'enlever à la recherche des
laboratoires privés des chercheurs privé
vous savez bien combien de chercheurs
vont oui et combien de chercheurs ne
trouve pas dans démarche parce que
recherche et découverte oui mais ça
n'est pas automatique
démarche international
parce que
finalement
il ne manquera plus que
le vôtre c'est le vôtre et ce sera
Emmanuel Macron j'imagine
si j'en ai jamais eu
[Musique]
alors il y a déclaration de candidature
journal de 20h ouais et la journée
d'hier
montre que c'est plus facile de
critiquer les politiques que de
s'avancer sur le ring et devenir
soi-même
un acteur du jeu ça montre quoi
ça mon Thomas vous l'avez vu donc et
puis j'aime pas j'aime pas taper sur sur
les gens qui sont à terre déjà il est
déjà à terre pour vous il y a un moment
très difficile pour lui oui oui mais bon
il a choisi des thèmes excessif
et la fébrilité qu'il a montré hier
montre que il sent lui-même que c'est M
ne correspondent pas à ce que l'opinion
il va avoir du mal pour les signatures
enfin tu tu sais
je suis là pour ça est-ce qu'il peut la
sauver non
je suis très très frappé par
une ou deux choses
j'ai regardé regarder non parce que
c'était intense homme très difficile à
supporter pendant 4 x 3 heures de temps
les débats entre guillemets des
républicains
alors il y a deux réflexion la première
c'est qu'aucune personnalité ne se
détache des autres et c'est mauvais
signe pour pour une pour une élection
présidentielle et en toque une
personnalité ne se détache des autres
c'est le premier. Il y a un deuxième.
C'est que
j'ai été frappé que un sujet soit à peu
près totalement tu as besoin de toi
alors il y avait
des heures et des dizaines d'heures sur
l'immigration sur la sécurité
l'immigration mais
une chose qui était absente alors qu'ils
vont donner de l'argent à tout le monde
de
fonctionnaires en multipliant
il y a une chose qui était
comment fait-on pour
reconquérir
les parts de marché la production
industrielle et Agricole tout ce qui a
été perdu par notre pays sous l'heure
j'allais dire sur l'Eure prééminence
alors qu'il était tôt pouvoir pendant
des décennies est cette question de que
j'appelle moi celle de la reconquête
industrielle Agricole et de services
cette question là la dynamique du pays
pour se pour saisir à bras-le-corps
les défis de notre temps était à peu
près totalement absente et donc je
trouve et c'est la même chose chez est
mort évidemment donc le 7 cet
aveuglement sur les difficultés que nous
rencontrons parce que le contrat social
français n'est-ce pas nous sommes un
pays dans lequel l'éducation est
totalement gratuite regarder autour de
nous les autres pays la santé totalement
gratuite l'assurance chômage et présente
la retraite avec toutes les difficultés
là pour tout le monde ce contrat social
la 7 7 7 immense chaîne de solidarité
folle à financer et pour la finance et
il faut quoi il faut des citoyens
nombreux et du travail et du travail je
vais revenir je vais revenir j'ai de la
production voilà
aujourd'hui
selon vous à pouvoir battre Emmanuel
Macron
l'hypothèse oui selon laquelle où on se
trouverait devant un risque extrémiste
en France je la récup n'y croyait pas
c'est pas que je n'y crois pas je veux
me battre contre non mais oui mais vous
voyez quand on quand on dit
dans une mission aussi importante que la
vôtre oui tant de gens écoute quand on
dit
oui il y a un risque vous à créditer la
démarche et donc moi je suis dans une
situation à je ne parle pas de risques
et en plus dans une situation de combat
je m'engage ré je suis dans une
situation de
Jean-Jacques Bourdin oui c'est
jamais dans le monde et dans aucun pays
elle n'en fait du bien jamais vous
pouvez chercher dans toute l'histoire
récente et plus ancien chaque fois que
vous organiser un pays autour de
l'affrontement de communautés en trail
autour de toutes les questions qui
passent leur temps à crispé à exciter
allumer le feu entre les gens chaque
fois vous affaiblissent est le pays et
ceci n'est pas une conviction
d'aujourd'hui je me suis toujours battu
sur cette ligne on était hier j'avais
été frappé je suis meilleur que moi je
pars le matin oui c'était magnifique
d'abord c'était absolument superbe vous
y étiez le 10 août du président de la
République était superbe c'était c'était
bon parce que c'était profond et je me
disais voilà donc une femme
noir
étrangères
1937 oui parce
française
qui s'engage au service de la France au
point de risquer sa vie
et dans laquelle la communauté nationale
peut se reconnaître il y avait deux
choses hier pour moi la première de les
chaussures que j'avais senti sur la
première il y avait une gaieté comme si
50 ans après sa mort la gaieté de
Joséphine Baker le la joie de vivre
l'envie de vivre de cette femme qui a
poussé l'instinct maternel jusqu'à
adopter 12 enfants abandonnés
avec toutes les difficultés que l'on que
l'on sait qu'elle a rencontré
sa raisonné il y avait encore des ondes
de de joie de vivre et la deuxième chose
je me disais
c'est assez éclairant parce que je
préfère de loin une France qui a
Joséphine Baker dans ses rangs une
France qui exclut Joséphine Baker parce
que la couleur de sa peau son origine ou
sa manière d'être aurait scandalisé
essaie de je trouve que ce que le
Président de la République a réussi à
dire très bien c'est que je suis pas
seulement moi qui le dit c'est pas par
esprit partisan mais ce qui est est
autour de moi qui sont pas de politique
des a même chose c'est que
c'est la France là il y avait une part
essentielle de la France
François Bayrou la maison comme une
très masculine
dans la direction de femmes que d'hommes
c'est un engagement les 4 grands patrons
qui était qui sont
[Musique]
Jean-Jacques Bourdin
nous ne pouvons plus jouer n'est rusé
avec cette nécessité que l'équilibre
entre femme et homme soit garantie et je
m'en porte garant que autant que que je
puisse j'ai montrer toute ma vie oui que
les femmes étaient dans la direction de
notre mouvement au premier rang François
Bayrou c'est une copropriété semoule
coopérative c'est
parce que chacun reste un peu chez soi
quand même on apporte à l'ensemble tout
ce qu'il a et tout ce qu'il est donc
vous venez avec comme vous venez avec
votre histoire vous venez avec votre
patrimoine si vous en avez vous venez
avec votre crédit auprès des Français et
tout cela s'associer dans une dynamique
un tout petit peu sur ce point
c'est pas quelque chose d'arrêter c'est
quelque chose qui bouge puisque ce que
nous avons accepté tous ces 1
qu'on ne ferai rien les uns contre les
autres pas de Guerlain dire si la
présidentielle au moins mais oui
il y aura
les mêmes candidats à l'élection
législative
choisir les meilleurs mais nous avons
accepté quelque chose d'extrêmement
important qui est le principe même
d'ailleurs d'organisation de l'Union
européenne nous avons accepté que ceux
qui veulent tu avancer ensemble aller
plus loin ensemble plus le faire sans
avoir des freins de la part des autres
c'est ce que l'appel en Europe les
coopération renforcée toutes les
politiques sont plastifiées par tous les
pays européens mais ceux qui veulent
aller de l'avant sur plusieurs sujets le
mot par exemple
aller de l'avant et les autres d'une
certaine manière seront entraînés par ce
mouvement alors vous pouvez dire que je
suis optimiste voulais dire que je suis
idéaliste il y a pire reproche que cela
je pense que quand on veut faire bouger
les choses il faut être optimiste et
idéaliste à François Bayrou vous n'aimez
pas la tête
je n'aime pas la dette mauvaise oui
parce qu'on rembourse 3000
€ en développant le pays en faisant de
la croissance les Allemands ont montré
qu'on pouvait augmenter la dépense
publique et faire baisser la part de la
date dans les contes de la nation
pourquoi si vous avez une bête qui
augmente de
5 % de la croissance du pays en deux ou
trois ans arrive à 10 % la part de la
Bête baisse vous comprenez ce oui c'est
ça voilà et c'est pourquoi je vous dis
que la reconquête de la production la
reconquête de l'Industrie la reconquête
de l'agriculture la reconquête aussi des
services nouveau tout cela c'est la
condition du développement du
rééquilibrage des comptes et aussi du
contrat social et le déficit de la
balance commerciale de la France et bien
c'est qui vous mettez le dois envoyer
qui se creuse de moins en moins moi je
ne comprends pas que oui chaque
interview vous ne vous faites pas vous
c'est un nouveau générique oui chaque
interview Laborde pas cette question
mais oui la France où est en déficit où
ils sont commerce extérieur de quelque
chose comme 70 milliards + encore plus
de 80 milliards aujourd'hui ça dépend de
moi 70 mois
7070 milliards l'Allemagne et un
excédent de
les Allemands sont pas plus intelligente
que les Français ils ne travaillent pas
plus les Allemands ne travaille pas
davantage non grosso-modo le niveau du
pays est à peu près le même ils ont la
même venez on nous a dit pour longtemps
c'est c'est la monnaie et puis au fond
on paie le travail à peu près au même
niveau comment se fait-il que nous
acceptions une telle situation d'échec
nationale et pour moi le un des thèmes
principaux devrait être celui-là et nous
allons vous savez que j'ai la lance
habilité de du Commissariat au Plan nous
allons sortir une étude qui montre pour
produit par produit où nous sommes
déficitaires il y a quelque chose que
nous sommes fait 900 produits et ce qui
m'exaspère aux enfin ce qui est pour moi
à motif de
mobilisation intérieur je veux bien
qu'on soit déficitaire sur des
des produits que nous n'avons pas sur
notre sol j'ai pas les hydrocarbures on
les a pardon je reviens on peut les
remplacer oui c'est pour ça qu'il faut
produire de l'électricité mais mais
comment un pays qui fabrique des
satellites des fusées des avions des
voitures parmi les meilleurs du monde
comment est-il incapable de faire des
produits je sais pas je dis toujours des
machines à laver les produits du
quotidien aucun des produits du
quotidien les Allemands ont vous avez en
tête
dans les foyers acheter et choisis nous
avons à reconquérir pied à pied
c'est-à-dire produit par produit et ça
se fait par l'association entre l'État
et les entreprises et les grandes
entreprises soit capable de les à soir
autour de la table pour avoir une
stratégie de reconquête merci d'être
venu nous voir ce matin sur RMC BFM TV
de 8h53